You're going to the Riviera Maya.
You have to stop by Ishkaret Ecopark.
We went with our three kids
and there were so much to do.
We spent the entire day there exploring everywhere.
We walked through my iron ruins and ecological exhibits.
We Learned so much about ancient mind,
culture and history
and got to explore
the beautiful landscape of the sonotes and jungle.
The kids water park area was a huge hit
with ropes courses and swimming holes.
We Learned tons about local coral reef ecology.
At the aquarium
we had the best buffet lunch
with traditional Mexican staples
and peruse some Mayan crafts.
This is definitely a must do if you're in the Yucatan.